[Musik]
wie ist es wichtig dass das thema diese
multi kulti sind geständig
ein schweizer von der kleinsten jahr
anders und darum machst du auch nicht
viel gedanken darüber was zumindest
christian 9
sie sind banker cafeteria leiter
kinderbetreuer sie kommen aus thailand
kolumbien oder vietnam
zwölf junge männer neun verschiedene
nationalitäten eine crew eine breakdance
crew
diese jungen männer leben wie in einer
großen familie
wie geht das warum kann hier jeder mit
jedem egal woher er kommt davon handelt
dieser film
es ist ahnungslos
dieses wochenende verbringen die jungen
tänzer vorwiegend im auto alles für
einen battle einen wettkampf in dem sie
sich mit anderen breakdance gruppen aus
europa messen wollen
es geht um 1000 euro preisgeld vielmehr
aber um ruhm und ehre
der weg führt weiterhin 1 nach
frankreich das als eine hochburg in
sachen breakdance gilt sechs stunden
fahrt nehmen die jüngst in kauf
[Musik]
das ist kein weekend trip ans meer
wer als breakdancer etwas auf sich hält
muss sein können beweisen auch außerhalb
der landesgrenzen
solche reisen schweißen die jungs
zusammen zu einer crew in der einzig
zählt was sie machen nicht woher sie
sind
[Musik]
italien wird seine firma ist das grüß
gott und gleichzeitig eine religion oder
nationalität
das spielt keine rolle richtige
kommunikation und dramatische zeit
[Musik]
der ehrgeiz ist der motor die
selbstdisziplin ihr trainer sie meldeten
sich selbst motivieren sich gegenseitig
zum durchhalten denn hinter ihren tricks
steckt jahrelange arbeit und es
funktioniert sie behaupten sich seit
langem als eine der erfolgreichsten
breakdance gruppen der schweiz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ghost rockz nennen sie sich und bereits
zwei mal konnten sie an der
weltmeisterschaft den ball auf die er
teilnehmen
wenn sie fliegen wirbeln und sich auf
dem kopf drehen sind sie alle gleich
sie sind breakdancer sogenannte boys im
arbeitsleben könnten ihre welten
unterschiedlicher nicht sein
zum beispiel michael die lehre als
metallbauer hat er noch durchgezogen
seither versucht er vom tanzen zu leben
am vormittag ist seine computer zeit
während andere am schreibtisch ihre
korrespondenz erledigen macht er es auf
seine art
michelle hat eine eigene breakdance
schule wo er sich um den nachwuchs
kümmert er gibt workshops und
organisiert kleine wettkämpfe für kinder
und jugendliche michael kam mit drei
jahren aus kolumbien in die schweiz
heute ist er 26 er wohnt noch bei seiner
mutter in seinem ehemaligen kinderzimmer
ein bettgestell wieder nicht ein
breakdancer muss sein zimmer jederzeit
umfunktionieren können halter anhand von
mache buch viel platz da mache der name
ist so gefühllos gang ja interesse galt
den ich spiele privat gern weitermachen
und zwar rasch
der streit der beim ray garner buch das
könnte auch die musik drin jahre wenn es
jetzt hart und den penis geschäften
immer gewisse kraft und schachteln und
sowie die alkohole und in eine
sammelklage bei mir in der straße zum
glück nicht so vielfach reaktion sondern
ich können trainieren das ist gratis
[Musik]
vincenzo lima sie er ist italiener
breakdancer und banker sein büro liegt
direkt am zürcher paradeplatz
seit einigen monaten arbeitet er bei der
privatbank julius bär
daneben schreibt der 26 jährige noch an
seinem marketing masterarbeit im projekt
1 team übernimmt er so etwas wie die
manager funktion muss sich ab und zu mal
in friesack jetzt das stop me zeigt das
sind doch schließlich oder ameise von
luft wasser als jüngster so machen ja
das sagen es doch wieder geschafft haben
oder wir versuchen also jedenfalls ich
versuche natürlich nicht fehlen wird das
waren nicht die ganze messe vincenzo
sieht sich als leben der beweis dafür
dass seine zwei welt nur scheinbar
unvereinbare sind er hat keine mühe sich
an die spielregeln in der bankenwelt
anzupassen
auf der bank möglich
und das ist in diesem training oder so
ist das k wort also brauchen damit würde
die wand und das spürte alles
interessiert
[Musik]
nicht immer geht es um wettkämpfe die
breakdancer haben auch eine bühnenshow
zu bieten
dafür werden sie in der ganzen schweiz
gebucht es ist samstagmittag gehören der
crew sind gerade erst aufgestanden was
für eine diskussion sorgt über disziplin
und fit sein
[Musik]
die zahl zu lahm so schnell wachsen
ich sah mich gestimmt
ein wichtiges bett schlaft ihr vor dem
auftreten nach die tanzschritte können
zum glück alle in schlaf die
choreografien sind selber einstudiert
und lange erprobt
pro jahr treten ghost rockz an dutzenden
von chance auf eine show besteht aus
gruppen elementen und einzel momenten in
denen jeder seine besondere spezialität
präsentieren darf
die meisten bekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von der bühne auf den pausenhof john lee
ist vietnamese er kam mit vier in die
schweiz
der heute 26 jährige betreut eine
kinderhort gruppe in st gallen die kids
wissen von seinen tanzkünsten und wenn
zeit ist verrät ihnen neue tricks der
kinderhort ist wie sonst breakdance
gruppe kunterbunt gemischt die
kulturunterschiede fallen ein vor allem
am mittagstisch auf die masse dann ja
vier schwarze wenn du mir jetzt vor der
schwarzen finish schlimm oder so andere
regional- und schwarzes auto bitte hin
zum beispiel wenn sie mal schwarze dem
bms es gebe weniger was wenn die chemie
ist das normal aber andere gruppe leider
seltenheit wie das schwarze meer mit dem
move oder oder weniger und für mich ganz
normal den märkten schotter unterschied
sorgen hat das kv gemacht china bleibt
der breakdance unterricht für kinder als
der zivildienst anstand hat er die
gelegenheit genutzt und ging in den hort
er wollte für den tanzunterricht seine
pädagogischen fähigkeiten verbessern und
mehr über den umgang mit kindern lernen
sandra schmidt da mit mir später nicht
nur fleisch erstmal fritz wenig nur
fleisch die arbeit hier hat sie so gut
gefallen dass er nach dem zivildienst
geblieben ist und ob unsere hunde immer
noch einmal geheilt wurde nicht
widersetzen damit zuvor gemachte helfen
so schnell
ja ich hatte schöne band wirklich sehr
wohl jeder einzeln da macht es spaß
[Musik]
auch er führt tagsüber ein bürgerliches
leben bonn mit vollem namen paris mon
krawatte der thailänder ist mit 30 der
älteste und deshalb der inoffizielle
chef der gruppe
er führt eine kleine cafeteria in zürich
von 90 jahren eine art vaterrolle bei
ghost rockz ein und kümmert sich um den
nachwuchs vor allem im tänzerischen
sinne aber nicht nur die jüngeren der
breakdancegruppe rufen ihn auch
anwenders leben probleme macht oder
kommen vorbei wenn sie hunger haben
gerade erfreut sich der 23 jährige henry
an seiner einzigen warmen mahlzeit für
heute sind wir frauen ja ein bisschen 22
die meistens nasa aber behielt hat
bestätigt habe wir verhungert immer noch
bonn sagt breakdance sei die beste
lebensschule
man lernt macher zu sein und nicht
zuschauer darum packte an wo er kann und
setzt sich für die jüngeren ein
[Musik]
und sie sind bei uns wichtigste
schützlinge die sogenannten kleinen die
jungen release sang 20 jahre und jan 18
jahre alt seit kurzem wohnen der
vietnamese und der schweizer gemeinsam
in einer wg und seit kurzem können sie
auch ihren traum leben in einer
demokratisch abgehaltenen sitzung wurden
die kleinen in die gruppe gewählt
sie möchten voll auf die karte projekt
entsetzen und wollten schon lange zug
ausdrucks gehören zum ersten mal durfte
hier eine kecke von der schweiz und das
ist nach gusto und einfach die jungs ein
make-up fasziniert wie einfach sie sind
ganz anders die andere
die parole heißt sie habe zu viel
energie beim tanzen und dann auch noch
cool gefunden und frankreich weil ich
wollte eigentlich sodann zu können
jan und st trainieren täglich kleine
tricks üben sie auch mal im wohnzimmer
die praxis meiner familie und das sie
behandelt das aber wie ihre kinder zu
erziehen da ist etwas kritisch und zu
mir dachte immer noch auf der autobahn
quer durch frankreich in einer stunde
sollten die jungs ihr ziel eine
kleinstadt namens eden an der belgischen
grenze erreichen
der aufwand um an solchen wettkämpfen
mitzumachen ist groß kostet viel zeit
und auch geld
der ganze fahrt über zerstört und das
battle ist im gegensatz zu fahren sind
kurz
logisch denn das battle und würde am
nächsten tag war der kurze zitate knapp
vor wettkampfbeginn erreichen die jungs
jetzt gilt es ernst
anmelden und aufwärmen die verspannung
von der autofahrt abschicken
vor und nach dem kampf herrscht
familiäre stimmung
man kennt sich man kennt ghost rockz da
die jungen tänzer seit jahren in europa
an vettels teilnehmen und sich einen
namen gemacht haben gut wir hatten eine
lange reise sei dann losgefahren gleich
treffen hier die teams im sogenannten
circle den kreis aufeinander messen im
tanz wer der stärkere ist
[Musik]
ich spiele mit spielern weil sie mit
unser spiel mitspielen zu können ein
spiel spielen
der erste battle der erste kampf beginnt
die ghost rockz jungs teilen sich in
zwei gruppen auf der chef von tanzt mit
der zwei kleinen team die gegnerischen
gruppen schicken abwechselnd einen
tänzer in die mitte man tanzt
gegeneinander an und misst so die kräfte
wer den kampf gewinnt entscheidet eine
jury
bonn und die kleinen überstehen die
erste runde doch in der zweiten ist
bereits schluss
doch trotz des frühen ausscheidens ist
bunt stolz auf seine schützlinge
er hat jahrelang an sie geglaubt und
heute können sie international mithalten
ja sowieso als und kollegen bedeutet
wieso lachen ist ja wie wir uns das
nichts angeht
wir sind jetzt auf ein miteinander
[Musik]
drinnen kommen die großen von ghost
rockz erst richtig in fahrt
sie sind noch im rennen um den sieg
beeindruckend gegner und jury mit wilden
drehungen und akrobatischen verrenkungen
[Musik]
vincenzo sohn john young und michael
kommen runde um runde weiter
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und beim istaf perfekt
unter dem motto musik tanzt die lettern
[Musik]
das video
breakdancer sein ist für die jungen
männer viel mehr als ein hobby es ist
eine philosophie einer die sie täglich
zu leben versuchen die vor allem eines
beinhaltet ausgrenzung und
andersartigkeit gibt es nicht jeder ist
teil der familie und möglich ist alles
[Musik]